Hey, everyone.
My name's Jared.
>> My name's Gabriele.
>> And my name is Jessica.
In the coming weeks and months you are
going to be learning the foundational
skills used every day by iOS developers.
You'll also be learning the Swift
programming language, which is
Apple's custom language designed for
iOS, Mac OS, and Watch OS development.
>> Before going any further,
you'll need to download and
install the core tool for
any iOS developer, Xcode.
Xcode is Apple's integrated
development environment,
which in layman's terms is the place
where you build your apps.
Downloading Xcode is simple.
It's available for
free on the App Store app on your Mac.
>> If you need additional help
you can find instructions below.
Depending on your Internet speed
however, this download can take a while.
But don't worry, go ahead and
grab something to drink.
We'll have some things to keep
you busy in the meantime.